we got pulled over well garage sale  hunting hey how you doing what's good my  friend how are you i'm holy [ __ ] garyvee  how are you i'm doing well how are you  man good man you're garage sale hunting  all right very good can i just get your  license i just need to take you down  saying that i uh spoke to you and you'll  be good to go all right man what's your  name james pleasure pleasure hang tight  one sec okay we asked the town for the  dash cam footage  he goes holy [ __ ]  [ __ ] well when did it pull over  someone just called they were concerned  i guess they thought  i was like did i miss a stop sign didn't  see oh the film and guess what he's  going check it out thank you brother it  was a pleasure such a pleasure man thank  you brother thank you have a great day  thank you take care guys thanks now to  hit the sale  good luck take care brother thank you